if business owners had hoped for a
pre-christmas boost they were set to be
disappointed
the netherlands is back in lockdown
non-essential shops hairdressers cinemas
and gyms
will have to stay closed until
mid-january
in what would usually be a bustling area
of the hague at this time of year
the streets were near empty but those
out and about
accepted the new rules it's necessary
because i i approve it completely they
implemented it too late should have
been done in middle of november
there are so many people that are sick
or that are
at hospitals helping them so i mean
we're fine you know
schools and day care centers will also
remain shut as the government tries to
fight
a rise in covet 19 cases social
interaction will be restricted
with people told to limit contact at
home to two people
that will be relaxed over christmas to
allow three visitors
in a televised address to the nation
prime minister mark rutter
insisted the restrictions were necessary
saying we have to bite through this very
sour apple before things get better
he's not the only european leader either
taking or contemplating
tough measures in germany where the
government announced a new lockdown
yesterday
drive-through christmas markets have
sprung up around the country
food can be bought for consumption in
vehicles one of the few seasonal options
for people who want to escape their
homes
it's a lovely idea we like it a lot
unusual ideas for unusual times
i think they've done really well at
creating some atmosphere especially for
the children
the german lockdown will come into force
tomorrow in an effort to tackle
stubbornly high infection rates and
people rushed to get their last minute
christmas shopping done
chancellor angela merkel forced to take
further steps after lighter restrictions
failed
and the italian government may be forced
to follow
in one of the main shopping streets in
rome the queues were not at the tills
but at covid test sites
worries have grown about crowds
gathering for christmas events
and a curfew and a ban on non-essential
movement of being contemplated
but in a region of spain they were
celebrating new freedom
skiers hit the slopes of catalonia for
the first time this season
after coveted restrictions were lifted
people intend to make the most of it
while it lasts michelle clifford sky
news